[Music]
ninth grade panzram 11th grade body
alright I'm Elle and that's my best
friend Lee oh we've been besties since
the day you were born
how have we stayed so close we have a
set of rules like rule number two never
tell anyone else our secrets or rule
number nine
Lee's older brother Flynn cases stupid
hot but totally off limit where did you
get the booze oh and rule number 10
never ever break rule number nine
[Music]
okay student council is expecting our
idea for the fundraiser today would
Flynn be working that UCB
I'll be there I promise blend filled in
the booth
so will you work the casillases
absolutely not my family you have zero
experience with dyes you've never even
had a boyfriend what get on that thing
like what are your make out girl sale
all made out with me okay so like 95% of
them make out with me why is it from a
boy
[Music]
I decided I had to see you here I was
thinking I was just your brothers and
going best friends yeah there's that
is there something going on between you
two nobody can know at least until I
tell you
for me there was nothing more important
than following the wars button lice step
right up ladies and gentlemen you can
either follow the rules or follow your
heart don't forget we're going out on
Saturday and I invited the Evanses do me
a favor be sweet to elf she kind of has
a crush on you
[Music]
you
you